is it possible to live thick boy  lifestyle and Primal Lifestyle the  answer is hell yeah because here's the  thing you don't have to change much you  can still live whatever sub Primal life  you're already living or you can live an  optimal Primal life like the thick boy  lifestyle but all you have to do with  the ancestral lifestyle is overlay that  onto your current infrastructure the  name is liver King because liver is King  start eating liver this is going to give  you more energy more drive more  determination to take Massive Action the  currency of life so you can Dominate and  Conquer in all your daily activities  liver King out